大家好，我叫戴维·布朗，这是一堂读写课。
在你的沟通中具有说服力，将对你本人、你的学业、你未来的
职业生涯等等都有用。
在沟通中更具说服力会对你有所帮助。
更具说服力意味着能够让别人做你希望他们做的事情。
做你希望他们做的事，完全正确。
如何才能更具说服力呢？
嗯，你必须学习，他们说，我曾经听说，一旦你了解了你谈话的对象，
你就必须学习如何用他们说话的方式来说话，这样他们才能更好地理解你。
但同时，用他们同样的词语，用他们同样的说话方式，
你必须教给他们一些东西。
一旦你进行了教导，他们就能够跟随你。
我认为每个人都有一些可以用来来说服我们的东西，只要他们有这个能力，
那些能够很好地交谈和表达自己的沟通技巧。
这不容易。
不，这不容易，我同意。
这可能很难。
这是我们可以改进的地方。
我们可以学习如何在沟通中更具说服力。
弗雷德里克·道格拉斯 (Fúléidélǐkè Dàogélāsī) 教会了我们一些关于说服力的重要理念，如果你读他的自传，我们今天会
读其中的一部分，你就会注意到他是多么有说服力。
他确实是一位非常优秀的作家，一位为这项事业 (shìyè) 写作的、极具说服力的伟大作家。
他的话语之所以能产生巨大影响，正是因为他非常有说服力。
那么，回顾一下，弗雷德里克·道格拉斯究竟是谁？
你可以在这里看到一组图片拼贴。
这是来自内战前和内战时期的。
你可以在这张照片中看到其他废奴主义者 (fèinú zhǔyì zhě) 的例子。
他生于1818年，卒于1895年。
他的鼎盛时期是在内战期间，他是一位非裔美国社会改革家、废奴主义者、
演说家 (yǎnshuōjiā)、作家和政治家。
可以请您帮我们读一下这部分吗？
在从马里兰州的奴隶生活中逃脱后，他成为了废奴运动的全国领袖。
以其强有力的演讲和著述闻名？
非常好。事实上，亚伯拉罕·林肯也知道这个人，并读过他的著作。
正是他的部分著作激励了林肯参与到这场运动中来。
我们这里有一个图表。
我们将思考一下关于弗雷德里克·道格拉斯我们已经了解了什么，
可能是我已经告诉过你的，或者你以前听说过的，或者你对
内战已经了解的内容。关于这位废奴主义者或内战，你已经知道了什么？
根据您告诉我的，嗯，他是一位非裔美国人，一个奴隶。
他从别人那里学会了阅读。
他没被教过阅读，是靠听别人读书学会的，对吗？
他去世时77岁，并且从马里兰州的奴隶生活中逃脱了。
一旦他学会了阅读，他就成了一位著名的 。
他是一位著名的作家。
作家。著名的废奴主义者和作家。非常好。
你听得很仔细。谢谢。
现在，这里有一些新的东西需要学习。关于弗雷德里克·道格拉斯，你有什么问题吗？
你想了解他的哪些方面？
哦。
好的，上面说他从奴隶生活中逃脱了。那之后他做了什么？
是的。
你认为你会怎么找到答案呢？嗯，我想我们可以通过今天的课程和活动来找到答案，
但实际上我们今天要读的内容更多是关于他逃跑之前的想法。
我仍然认为你可以对他当时必须做什么，或者是什么促使他能够逃脱有一些了解。
这也是一些你或许能够在今天这堂课之后
如果你想读完他的自传的话，可以读到的其他内容。
以及他的一些著作。我们有一些需要重点掌握的词汇。我们将阅读一段弗雷德里克·道格拉斯自传中的
段落，他在其中描述了自己学习读写的决心。
没有什么能阻止这个人。他尽其所能地教育自己，
在一个奴隶学习读写被视为非常禁忌的世界里。
好的。这些是我们在这里需要了解的一些词汇。我希望你看看这些词
以及它们的定义。我们有 "strategies" (策略 cèlüè)。你能为我读一下这里的定义吗？
巧妙的计策。巧妙的计策或为达到某一目标而使用的计划。
"Depravity" (道德败坏 dàodé bàihuài)。
我看不清。道德败坏或邪恶 (xié'è)。邪恶。
这个呢。"Chattel" (动产 dòngchǎn)。第一个词，这个怎么发音？
"Chattel" (chattel)。"Chattel"。听起来像法语，对吧？
一件物品或私有财产。被奴役的人在法律上
被视为 "chattel" (动产)。所以基本上就像一件没有价值的物品。他们仅仅被当作
物品，可以被使用然后丢弃的东西来对待。然后这个，"precepts" (准则 zhǔnzé / 戒律 jièlǜ)。"Precepts"。
指导行为的规则或原则。"Apprehension" (忧虑 yōulǜ / 理解 lǐjiě)。
你听到了吗。
"Apprehension"。你听到了吗？"Apprehension"。
恐惧。现在我听到了。对将要发生坏事的恐惧和焦虑。也指理解。
不。"Urchins" (顽童 wántóng / 小淘气鬼 xiǎo tǎoqìguǐ)。
"Urchins" 淘气的。不，我不知道这个怎么发音。
"Mischievous" (mischievous)。"Mischievous"。
通常指贫穷且衣衫褴褛的孩子。
有 "sea urchins" (海胆 hǎidǎn)。海胆是一种身上长满刺的海洋生物。
但你也可以用 "urchins" 来形容孩子，带有善意的淘气意味。
然后这个，"vindication" (证明无辜/正当 zhèngmíng wúgū/zhèngdàng)。"Vindication"。
以及 "vindication"。为某人洗清罪名。哦，还有证明。证明某人或某事是
正确或合理的证据。然后是 "abhor" (憎恶 zēngwù)。"Abhor"。怀着厌恶和憎恨看待。
和憎恨。
所以我们把它用作动词，去 "abhor" 某事物，即非常痛恨某事物。
这些词汇中的很多都确实突出了我们将在阅读中
一起讨论的一些内容。当我们阅读时，我们会尽量关注意义，尽管我可以帮助你发音，
但我不想让它（发音）成为障碍。